and now here's your host for the 80th
annual Academy Awards Jon Stewart
here you're here I can't believe it
you're actually here this is exciting
ladies and gentlemen good evening what
an exciting night these past three and a
half months have been very tough town
was torn apart by a bitter writer strike
but I'm happy to say that the fight is
over
so tonight tonight
welcome to the makeup sex of course
there is still obviously some collateral
damage left over from the strike
emotionally economically perhaps worst
of all the cancellation of the legendary
Vanity Fair Oscar party they said they
did it out of quote respect for the
writers and oh you know another way they
could show respect for the writers maybe
one day invites some of them to the
Vanity Fair Oscar party they would enjoy
it
I worry they won't mingle don't worry
they actually say that having the Oscars
help to end the strike that the idea
that getting the town back to work and
having an Oscar is one of the impetus to
to get things done which i think is
wonderful so if we could before we spend
the next 4 to 5 hours giving each other
golden statues let's take a moment to
congratulate ourselves tonight we look
beyond the dark days to focus on happier
fare this year's slate of Oscar
nominated psychopathic killer movies
does this town need a hug
what what what happened No Country for
Old Men Sweeney Todd there will be blood
all I can say is thank God for teen
pregnancy yeah no I need the country
agrees
get everybody up they needed that kind
of light-hearted fare there were if I
may
amazing performances this year and I
think everybody can agree on that there
really were this terrific
Daniel day-lewis remarkable Cate
Blanchett twice my friend Javier Bardem
Javier Bardem is Anton Chigurh
remarkable your work in No Country for
Old Men combining brilliantly Hannibal
Lecter's murderous Nisour the-- Hamels
wedge cut it was
Julie Christie was absolutely amazing
and away from her
brilliant movie was a moving story of a
woman who forgets her own husband
Hillary Clinton called it the feel-good
movie of the year
Diablo Cody what an amazing story
Shiro Juno such a great movie Diablo
Cody used to be an exotic dancer and now
she's an oscar-nominated screenwriter I
hope you're enjoying the pay cut it is I
don't know if you know this but if you
want to find out your stripper name at
home all you have to do is take your
pet's name and the street you grew up on
so that makes my stripper name Olympia
Dukakis
Democrats do have an historic race going
Hillary Clinton versus Barack Obama
normally when you see a black man or a
woman president an asteroid is about to
hit the Statue of Liberty
how will we know it's the future